und dass das labor für die europäische
pandemie bekämpfung steht in österreich
die allgemeine impfpflicht wird am
donnerstag im parlament abgestimmt und
wohl geschlossen damit es die regierung
in wien und mutiger als die heftig mit
den armen rudern der ampel koalition in
berlin die die allgemeine impfpflicht
zur gewissensfrage transformiert hat und
die entscheidung den abgeordneten zu
schieben will möglicherweise ein fall
von flucht aus der verantwortung
womit über die sinnhaftigkeit einer
solchen in pflicht noch nichts gesagt
ist
österreich liegt vor im pflicht für alle
jetzt in der phoenix runde
phoenix runde
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst die zugeschalteten roland
adrowitzer ist bei uns komponenten chef
des orf in wien sie waren auch mal
korrespondent hier in deutschland
gewesen aus stockerau zugeschaltet der
studie leiter des ard-studios schweden
oder dass er gesagt skandinavien
christian blenk haben und hier im studio
ist an mayet korrespondentin des
französischen
nachrichtenkanals france werk april also
frankreich 24 sendet also rund um die
uhr und kaya klappt da ist bei uns
redakteurin im ressort in politik bei
der welt und der welt am sonntag
wird denn die impfpflicht in österreich
die jetzt morgen eingeführt werden soll
verabschiedet werden soll im parlament
zu einem erfolgsmodell für die dortige
schwarz grüne koalition
das ist sehr umstritten ja sie wird
morgen beschlossen werden und zwar mit
einer großen mehrheit nicht nur mit der
mehrheit der beiden regierungsparteien
eben schwarz grün sondern auch mit den
stimmen der oppositionellen
sozialdemokraten und mit den meisten der
liberalen neos dagegen stimmen wird die
rechte freiheitliche partei die er seit
wochen eine ganz massive kann dann ging
die impfpflicht und überhaupt gegen die
meisten krone maßnahmen fährt ob es ein
erfolg wird oder nicht ist war aus dem
osten von anfang an ob sie eingeführt
wird das war eigentlich eine
gegenleistung die regierung war im
herbst gegen einen weiteren lockt darum
die landeshauptleute vergleichbar mit
einem deutschen ministerpräsidenten
haben sie der bundesregierung abgepresst
eigentlich bei einer krisensitzung in
tirol und die gegen forderungen aus wien
war dann eine allgemeine impfpflicht sie
wird nun morgen beschlossen werden sie
dritte mehreren phasen in kraft zunächst
nur in der informationsphase ab 16 märz
soll kontrolliert werden von der polizei
etwa bei verkehrskontrollen und dann
erst in einer dritten phase wenn es die
impft seien dann noch notwendig machen
dann wirklich massiv und auch
kontrolliert über die elektro wie das
genau aussieht werden wir im laufe der
sendung noch besprechen frau ist denn
ähnliches in frankreich denkbar da gibt
es ja schon eine impfpflicht endlich in
deutschland für pflegepersonal ich
glaube für polizei und feuerwehr noch
ist das auch eine option firma crowe
also die impfpflicht gibt es tatsächlich
seit mitte oktober für manche
berufsgruppen das betrifft vor allem die
das pflegepersonal
medizinische personal in krankenhäuser
aber in der allgemeinen pflicht kommt im
moment nicht infrage in frankreich summe
chrome hat schon von anfang an gesagt
bevor die impfstoffe überhaupt zur
verfügung standen das hat ja gesagt mit
mir wird es keine impfpflicht geben
dabei ist er geblieben aber die
diskussion gibt es trotzdem in
frankreich ob es nicht notwendig wären
ja die andere druckmittel inzwischen da
redet man auch gleich darüber dass jetzt
sagen wir eine alternative dann zur
allgemeinen impfpflicht ablenker in
schweden und in den anderen
skandinavischen ländern ist ja eine
impfpflicht wohl ein gesellschaftliches
no go also eher undenkbar so kann man
das sagen ich habe lange vor der sendung
darüber nachgedacht ob es das wort
überhaupt im schwedischen gibt eine
impfpflicht und es ist mir keinen
gefallen an man könnte das irgendwie
konstruieren aber es gibt es nicht und
das ist ja viel sagen die schwedinnen
und schweden brauchen keine pflicht
sondern sie brauchen behörden die ihnen
sagen was sie tun soll was sie nicht tun
sollen und das funktioniert in dieser
gesellschaft seit vielen vielen
jahrzehnten und das merkt man jetzt auch
in der krise das heißt wenn die
gesundheitsbehörde sagt geht und dass
durch impfen dann machen dass die
menschen hier die impfquote ist
vielsagend spricht für sich über 80
prozent sind mit der zweiten impfung
hier schon versorgt und bei der dritten
impfung geht es auch voran und ganz
ähnliches ist im nachbarland dänemark
erreicht die hochgezogene augenbraue von
mette fredriksen der ministerpräsidentin
und am nächsten tag werden termine
gebucht
in deutschland ist das leider nicht ganz
so da gibt es nicht so viel
gesellschaftlichen kommen über wichtige
grundlegende dinge im gegenteil dazu
legt man sich schon aus ganz anderen
anlässen wenn man jetzt mal ansieht
letztes jahr aber keiner von den
maßgeblichen politikern für eine impfung
plötzlich dann alle oder jedenfalls prix
maßgeblichen jetzt plötzlich merkt man
aber auch die frage ob sie notwendig so
nicht besprechen in der sendung noch
kann man denn sagen dass die impfpflicht
befürworter bei uns bereits den rückzug
auf leisen sohlen angetreten haben ich
glaube so weit würde ich nicht gehen was
stimmt der enthusiasmus von ende letzten
jahres ist verschwunden weil klar
geworden ist es gibt eben eine menge
offener fragen die sehr schwer zu lösen
sind angefangen von der frage wie viele
dosen brauchen wir überhaupt können wir
eine impfpflicht auf verdacht für den
nächsten herbst und winter überhaupt
beschließen wenn wir sagen die hilft gar
nicht mehr gegen uli kontny gut schützt
überhaupt die impfung noch wie lange
also da gibt es eine menge von offenen
fragen und deswegen gibt es da jetzt
auch eine kleine ratlosigkeit die sich
breit macht bei vielen abgeordneten kann
man sagen dass eben auch gerade die
gerichts festigkeit dass das rechtlich
wasserdicht ist ein großes problem ist
heute gab es zwar nicht zur impfpflicht
aber zu 2g regel in bayern auf dem beim
obersten verwaltungsgericht eine
entscheidung dass die für den
einzelhandel also nicht die supermärkte
und tankstellen aber den restlichen
einzelhandel
sie ist zwar nicht verfassungswidriger
weise moment was die verordnung angeht
rechtswidrig dass da ständig immer
wieder auch angst daher kommt oder dass
man da angst verspüren der politik dass
die gerichte eine möglicherweise dann
auch irgendwann das
bundesverfassungsgericht die parade für
genau das ist tatsächlich die grösste
angst und deswegen versucht man auch
diese anträge jetzt so wasserdicht wie
es nur geht zu formulieren damit all die
klagen die erwartbar sind in karlsruhe
dann eben kein erfolg finden und daher
gibt es auch eine menge von von
schwachstellen auch hans jürgen papier
der ehemalige präsident
bundesverfassungsgericht hat selbst auch
gesagt dass eine impfpflicht schwierig
sieht aus mehreren gründen also da wird
man sehr aufpassen müssen
sie haben gerade schon ein bisschen
angedeutet wie das jetzt passiert und
was wir morgen ab morgen passiert morgen
wird es mit allerhöchster
wahrscheinlichkeit durchs parlament
gehen ich glaube im februar beginnen
dann die frist dann gibt es vier wochen
schonfrist da wird noch nicht die
impfpflicht staatlicher seite
durchgesetzt aber dann wird's ernst wie
sie das eigentlich aus weil das in
deutschland auch ein wichtiges thema ist
die frage kann man das durchsetzen sehr
kontrolliert da eigentlich was und was
bedeutet es wenn jemand einer
gesetzlichen pflicht nicht nachkommt das
ist ja in österreich wie in deutschland
eine ordnungswidrigkeit mindestens wie
ist das in österreich also ist es ganz
kurz skizzieren könnten was da
österreich möglicherweise deutschland
mal wieder voraus hat
ja voraus hat man wird sehen es ist sehr
umstritten ist auch in den parteien
dafür sind sehr umstritten die umfragen
eine mehrheit der bevölkerung ist an
sich dagegen die diskussion geht
wirklich gar ganz quer durchs land aber
es ist vorgesehen dass ab dem 16 märz
kontrolliert wird und zwar von der
polizei etwa bei verkehrskontrollen das
dann auch wenn da nicht nur der
führerschein und die zulassung sondern
auch der impfpass kontrolliert wird es
sind strafen vorgesehen bis zu 600 euro
und zwar maximal vier mal im jahr also
bis zu 2400 euro man kann dann gegen
diese strafen vor verwaltungsgerichten
berufen das wird massiv werden das
werden sehr viele tun und dann ist sogar
theoretisch eine anhebung der steuer für
bis zu
3600 euro möglich dass das war das sieht
man auch dass das schon sehr sehr viel
auf die verwaltungsgerichte zukommen
wird die polizei hat natürlich keine
freude damit dass sie jetzt auch noch
den impfstatus der bevölkerung
stichprobenartig zumindest überprüfen
österreich hat eine ein system namens
elgar die elektronische gesundheitsakte
jeder staatsbürger ist über seine
versicherungsnummer in dieser
elektronischen akte registriert und ab
april wird dann routinemäßig zwei mal im
jahr abgeglichen werden automatisch ist
der oder die betreffende geimpft das
wird ausnahmen geben im prinzip hat ist
jeder der in österreich jede idee die in
österreich leben verpflichtet sich drei
mal impfen zu lassen die zwei von dem
plus puste aus völlig
bevölkerungsgruppen die mit aus
medizinischen gründen befreit sind auch
schwanger reagieren andere sind im
moment befreit aber dann kann das
wirklich aber eher nur wenn es notwendig
ist das ist noch die aus die
ausweichvariante
sollte omikron bis dahin vor abgeebbt
sein oder sollten sich dann doch so
viele impfen haben lassen österreich
liegt dabei der impfquote sehr stark
noch dann muss vielleicht diese dritte
phase gar nicht die kraft bringen ich
glaube daran fünf die regierung gut
jetzt würden die befürworter einer
impfpflicht ja sagen glückliches
österreich die haben wenigstens ein in
fleck ist das gibt es in deutschland
nicht wird es daran scheitern das ist
die größte krux bei der frage der
umsetzung es im register ist sehr
umstritten und stand jetzt sehe ich
dafür auch keine mehrheit karl
lauterbach selbst hat letztens gewarnt
vor einem ins register sagte das würde
viel zu lange dauern es aufzubauen und
es sei eben auch datenschutzrechtlich
sehr umstritten deswegen würde ich mal
stand jetzt davon ausgehen dass wir es
ohne ins register haben werden und dann
ist die große frage woher wissen wir wer
geimpft ist und wir nicht das wird dann
wahrscheinlich auf stichprobenkontrollen
hinauslaufen auf der straße zum beispiel
sind auch die fragen machen dass die
überlasteten gesundheitsämter macht das
die überlastete polizei wie oft kann man
dann überhaupt kontrollieren und wie
beeindruckt sind davon dann die
impfgegner werden die dann tatsächlich
der impfpflicht freunden das ist ja auch
noch eine große frage in unsere
umgangssprache hat sich ja das wort
blutgrätsche ein ja sozusagen
eingeschlichen wenn das alle wirklich
berechtigung hat der begriff
blutgrätsche dann das was man gerade in
frankreich vor hat nämlich mit denen
verweigern mit den impfgegnern da gibt
es jetzt wird massiver druck ausgeübt
weil es wird sogar ein bisheriges
impfpass umgetauscht in einen neuen und
nur mit dem kann man also die
wichtigsten öffentlichen verrichtungen
überhaupt noch machen es ist glaube ich
auch so dass man möglicherweise gar
nicht mehr zu seinem arbeitsplatz kommt
vielleicht
darf dort nicht hin dass könnten
arbeitsplatzverlust bedeuten ist das so
eine art gern so eine zwischenlösung ist
das weil man eine allgemeine impfpflicht
in frankreich unbedingt vermeiden will
oder ist das jetzt dem ja eigentlich ist
es ja nicht so sehr dem temperament von
micron geschuldet wir kennen ihn ja
etwas anders aber in frankreich ist ja
präsidentschaftswahlkampf ja also
letztendlich was jetzt in kraft tritt in
frankreich ist die 2g regelung die wir
auch in deutschland kennen der
unterschied glaube ich ist das in
frankreich die sogenannte 3g regelung
schon seit letztem sommer eingeführt
wurde das hat dazu geführt dass sehr
viele menschen viel mehr als in
deutschland sich impfen ließ also der
druck
im manual micron die regierung haben
schon angefangen im sommer letztendlich
den druck auf die ungeimpften aufzubauen
und jetzt geht man drüber zu 2g und
kritiker sagen in frankreich wie hier in
deutschland das ist letztendlich eine
impfpflicht durch die hintertür und
ich aber die regierung wird nicht so
weit gehen und lässt auch nicht wirklich
die debatte um eine impfpflicht aufgaben
die sagen ja wir wollen den ungeimpften
auf die nerven gehen also wie man york
rom hat sogar ein sehr wohl leeres wort
in einem interview dafür verwendet den
ich hier nicht wiederholen werde aber
aber so weit wird man nicht gehen eben
weil auch wahlen da sind und weil die
ungeimpften frankreich also dass die
zahl der ungeimpften ist niedriger als
in anderen ländern wie deutschland und
österreich wo es für manche notwendig
ist also also auch so makro auch im
wahlkampf dann etwas ungefährlicher er
banker jetzt ist die europäische union
ja eigentlich dazu da dass vergleichbare
lebensverhältnisse überall herrschen
deswegen gibt es ja auch eine
rechtseinheit auf der europäischen ebene
da kann aber beim info überhaupt nicht
die rede davon sein in skandinavien
sieht das alles etwas anders aus ich
glaube in dänemark gehörte immer zu ihm
berichts gebiet da steigen zwar die zahl
der neuinfektionen auch stark an wie in
anderen ländern aber da wird jetzt
gelockert wie das denn
es ist manchmal schwer zu verstehen wir
haben alle ja schon mit gefeiert mit in
denen denen als es hieß im september
freedom day alle maßnahmen wurden
aufgehoben und man hat wirklich wieder
konzerte gesehen was man seit einer
ewigkeit nicht mehr gesehen damit 50.000
menschen in einem raum die sich ein
konzert angeguckt haben das gab es
wieder in dänemark und dann kam omikron
diese zahlen sind wirklich in die höhe
geschossen es geht eigentlich woche für
woche geht die leiter weiter hoch
mittlerweile sind wir bei einem
incidents wert sieben tage
über 3000 das sind wahnsinns zahlen
trotzdem ist es so genau so wie sie
sagen dass die regierung darüber
nachdenkt die maßnahmen wieder
zurückzufahren die man dann noch mal
eingeführt hatte und das hat folgenden
grund mal guckt viel mehr
man lässt die intendantin inzidenz ein
bisschen bei seinen wirkt vielmehr auf
die krankenhaus zahlen wie sieht es denn
da eigentlich aus und die der
gesundheitsminister und die dänische
regierung sagen die krankenhäuser sind
nicht mehr so stark belastet wir haben
die erfahrung gemacht dass die
krankheitsverläufe milder sind und
deswegen glauben wir dass wir die
maßnahmen wieder lockern können also
sind ja insbesondere seit dezember
kultureinrichtungen geschlossen worden
und hat also versucht große
menschenansammlung ein stück zu
vermeiden und das ist dann wieder
aufgehoben worden und wenn wir mit den
menschen deutsch sprechen sagen sie das
leben ist fast normal geworden natürlich
gibt es die mundschutz pflicht und man
hält sich auch an abstände das versucht
man zu machen es ist ein sehr digitales
leben in dänemark wie in schweden das
heißt den impfpass den trick jeder in
seinem handy mit ich werde immer
ausgelacht wenn ich mit meinem deutschen
gelben impfpass zur impfung komme da
möchte mir keine kein mitarbeiter
irgendwas reinschreiben das kennt man
hier einfach nicht das läuft komplett
digital ein bisschen ungezogen ein
bisschen problemloser finde ich und mit
diesem im pass kommt man eben in
restaurants zum beispiel rein und so
glaubt man die lage besser kontrollieren
zu können trotz dieser hohen zahlen
jetzt können natürlich wenn gelockert
wird ein super spread event entstehen
bei irgendeinem konzert zum beispiel
dass da plötzlich wieder sich sehr viele
anstecken und dann würde ja auch viel
bewirkt ja viel auch die
hospitalisierung rate also die zahl der
kranken in krankenhäusern möglicherweise
wieder ansteigen das heißt also diese
achterbahnfahrt ist ja in ländern wie
dänemark und schweden seit ausbruch von
corona nichts ungewöhnliches
ja aber es ist jetzt in der mittlerweile
dritten und vierten welle schon ein
anderes bild die krankenhaus lage
oder überhaupt die mortalitätsrate war
in schweden am anfang eine katastrophe
sind viel zu viele menschen gestorben
weil schweben da unter umständen einen
anderen weg gewählt hat mittlerweile ist
das anders es gibt ja auch hier
vorschriften und restriktionen und in
dänemark wie in schweden ist die
krankenhaus situation nicht so
angespannt wie es vielleicht im jahr
zuvor war deswegen traut man sich auf
jeden fall in dänemark diesen schritt
und schweden würde ich sagen ist immer
ein tick kontinuierlicher durch diese
pandemie gegangen die behörden empfehlen
maßnahmen sie werden aber
hier und da nicht immer so durchgesetzt
wie wir das vielleicht aus deutschland
können also jedem der nach schweden
reist fällt sofort auf da trägt nicht
jeder mundschutz das hat sich nicht
geändert auch wenn die menschen
natürlich sagen wenn ihr in der u bahn
fahrten in den dicht gedrängten bussen
fahrrad ist es besser einen zu tragen
die schwimmen und schweden machen das
nicht und trotzdem ist die situation ja
so dass trotz der hohen incidents zahlen
die lage in den krankenhaus in
krankenhäusern noch relativ ruhig ist
auf jeden fall in den intensivstationen
sind die zahlen lange nicht so hoch
deswegen trauen sich beide länder diesen
kurs
glaubst du in österreich in frankreich
in schweden gehabt jetzt gehört gibt es
selbst wenn es dort auch konflikte gibt
zumindestens klare ansagen und
vielleicht sogar einen relativ deutlich
vorgezeichneten weg sie haben es gerade
schon angesprochen also die impfpflicht
erst sollte es nicht kommen oder auf
keinen fall oder verspreche ihnen oder
schwere kommt kann ich dann aber alle
geschworen dass sie kommt jetzt wissen
wir nicht genau ob sie kommt wir haben
schon über register gesprochen das ja
weil es nicht vorhanden ist die sache ja
erheblich erschwert wie lässt sich das
überhaupt diese dieses diese politische
verhalten das ist ja nicht nur die ampel
koalition also auch die vorhergehende
kroko die da nicht immer sehr deutlich
wahr und gut einzuschätzen was wie
würden sie das jetzt im vergleich auch
mit den ländern die wir hier noch
vertreten haben denn einschätzen wie die
deutsche politik gerade in diesem
wichtigen megathema das wichtigste thema
überhaupt im moment gerade agiert ich
glaube es war ein fehler dass man so
früh so klar die impfpflicht
ausgeschlossen hatte ich erinnere mich
noch an herrn spahn und frau merkel die
damals bei jeder öffentlichen
veranstaltungen mit bürgern gefragt
worden sind können sie es denn wirklich
versprechen man hört ja auf social media
das ist vielleicht hinter den kulissen
doch kommen könnte dann dieses wir
versprechen dass euch und ich glaube da
hätte man sich nicht so weit aus dem
fenster lehnen dürfen eben aufgrund all
der unwägbarkeiten die eine pandemie mit
sich bringt jetzt muss man das alles
ausbaden
dieses gebrochene versprechen und die
ampel regierung sie haben es
angesprochen hat die verantwortung
abgegeben an den bundestag auf druck der
fdp weil man eben in der ampel eine
gemeinsame linie zu finden ist quasi
unmöglich und jetzt darf sich der
bundestag damit herumschlagen und wir
sehen auch es gibt sehr holprig voran
woran liegt das india ist das föderale
system zu stark gibt können nach dem
motto viele köche verderben den brei
das war der unterschied ist augenfällig
ich meine in frankreich gibt es wahlen
in schweden gab es neulich wahlen in
österreich gibt es immer wieder wahlen
also das ist ja kein argument zu sagen
wir sind permanent im wahlkampf woran
liegt das naja jetzt als minor leagues
am verfahren also wir haben jetzt eine
eine abstimmung geplant die ohne
fraktionszwang stattfindet das heißt da
kann man sich jetzt wirklich viel zeit
nehmen und fraktionsübergreifend
gruppenanträge formulieren bündnisse
schmieden also dass das dauert ja das
ist ein ganz anderer weg als wenn die
regierung etwas vorgibt das ist in dem
fall auch als man kann es auch gut
begründen also man kann sagen das ist
eine ethische entscheidung wie wir es
bei der organspende zb hatten anfang
vergangenes vergangenen jahres aber es
führt eben auch dazu dass es jetzt eben
sehr lange dauert und dass viele offene
fragen sind und das von der regierung
selbst von scholz von lauterbach keine
klare linie und keine klare führung zu
sehen und die deutschen war nie am
anfang der korona pandemie also im
ersten halben jahr 2020 geradezu die
musterknaben bei der bekämpfung das ist
anders geworden ist dass in frankreich
auch registriert worden sie sich da in
deutschland die politik geändert hat
auch die reaktionen der bevölkerung
im laufe der pandemie oder ist man da er
auf eigene land fokussiert seit anfang
der pandemie schaut man immer auf
deutschland also wie vorher bei anderen
krisen so
und ich glaube am anfang war dann für
deutschland eine große bewunderung
allein für die tatsache dass so viele
testen plötzlich hier zur verfügung
stand dass die ersten test hier erfunden
worden sind das dann auch noch ein
impfstoff gaben aus deutschland und und
weil eben deutschland durch die erste
welle der pandemie sowie auch die
luftbrücke von intensivpatienten und
frankreich nach deutschland
und dafür war man auch in frankreich
sehr dankbar weil die erste welle in
frankreich im vergleich zu deutschland
welt und war also und dann hat man
gesehen eben großer bewunderung wie sich
diese wie sich alles umgedreht hat und
dass sich so viele menschen in
deutschland geweigert haben sich zu
impfen das war für viele franzosen nicht
ganz verständlich und ich glaube das war
aber auch für die wahlkampf war ja auch
daran und das hat auch nicht geholfen im
letzten jahr also plötzlich war das von
der bildfläche
verschwunden und und das hat man ja in
frankreich mit
überraschungen brachte diese konflikte
die daraus jetzt noch entstehen die gibt
es ja in deutschland wie in frankreich
bei uns nennt man sie verharmlosen
spaziergänger in frankreich gibt es ja
die schule schon also die gelb westen
bewegung league gab es vor allen dingen
wegen klimaschutzfragen ein solches
verhalten aber wird ja diese oder heizt
ja eigentlich diese konflikte an die
gibt es allerdings in frankreich ja auch
es gibt ja auch massive proteste gegen
die maßnahmen der regierung was einer
beschränkung angeht und auch was ihre
faktische impfpflicht ja also ich glaube
es gibt zwei unterschiedliche strömungen
im moment in frankreich es gibt auf der
einen seite tatsächlich auch viele
demonstrationen in vielen städten von
impfgegnern
die auch vergleichbar sind so zu das was
man in deutschland sind und dann gibt es
auch noch eine große bewegung die
angetrieben wird von den lehrern und den
eltern weil weil die die protokolle die
die gesundheit protokolle die man in den
französischen schulen eingeführt hat um
die schulen offen zu halten die sind
extrem kompliziert geworden über die
zeit und das versteht kein mensch also
aber ich würde diese zwei bewegungen
quasi nicht miteinander vergleichen weil
die die lehrer und die eltern die morgen
wieder auf die schule gehen sind
eigentlich dafür dass die schule offen
bleiben das ist restriktionen gibt dass
es maßnahmen gibt dass es impfungen gibt
aber die wollen klare ansage haben und
da hat die regierung in den letzten
willen dieser sogenannte spaziergänge in
deutschland werden von gewalt begleitet
ist das in frankreich im moment nicht
dass er bei arthrose zwar möglicherweise
in österreich etwas anders ich habe
glaube darauf hingewiesen dass morgen im
parlament eigentlich alle parteien
zustimmten außer der sp höhe ich glaube
im moment bei umfragen bei 20 prozent
damit doppelt so stark wie die afg in
deutschland die ja hier auch versucht
mit weniger erfolg die impfgegner um
sich zu scharen da gibt es auch massive
proteste werden die denn jetzt wenn
morgen die parlamentsmehrheit im
nationalrat in wien es war macht diese
impfpflicht die allgemeine zu
verabschieden wird denn da
möglicherweise die konflikt werden die
konflikte auf der straße wieder
verstärkt werden wird es möglicherweise
wieder meldet gewalttätigkeiten auch in
österreich geben
jeden samstag wird die wiener innenstadt
lahmgelegt von zehntausenden
demonstranten nicht nur in wien auch in
den anderen landeshauptstädten in
salzburg in innsbruck in klagenfurt
gehen jedes wochenende tausende menschen
auf die straßen der ton ist teilweise
sehr teilweise widerliche antisemitische
begleiterscheinungen impfen macht frei
und unendlicher gefährlichen schwachsinn
der dort geleistet wird und der obmann
der freiheitlichen partei herbert kickl
hat
erkannt dass er das quasi monopol hat
jetzt auf die als impfgegner es gibt
aber außer ihm jetzt auch noch eine
partei namens mfg ist bereits in eines
der landesparlamente mit sechs prozent
eingezogen das sind ganz
aggressive impfgegner um sie wahr haben
auch vor dass die bundesweit kandidieren
werden sie liegen derzeit in umfragen
deutlich über der schwelle dass sie in
den nationalrat einziehen würden sie
liegen ungefähr bei 6 prozent in
umfragen und servus gesagt 20 prozent
die freiheitlichen wieder nach allem was
sie in den vergangenen jahren erlebt
haben stichwort pisa muss die partei
zerlegt hat wo sie auf bis zu 12 13
heruntergefallen sind jetzt sind sie mit
diesem amt im kurs mit dieser massiven
wirklich aggressiven rhetorik nur ein
beispiel erbe kickl hat bei seiner
letzten rede auf einer dieser
demonstrationen wörtlich die verlobten
regierung dass er die regierung uns
verlobten regierung bezeichnet die die
weg geräumt werden muss das sind töne
die ich sie schon sehr bedenklich sind
dies ist auch schon zu gewalttätigen
szenen gekommen bei diesen
demonstrationen und das ist nicht
anzunehmen und ist eher zu erwarten dass
diese impfpflicht der wirklich auch bei
jenen die an sich für die maßnahmen der
regierung sind nicht unumstritten ist
dass das vielleicht die stimmung wieder
anheizen könnte der banker gibt es denn
in den skandinavischen konsens und
ausgleichs gesellschaften auch
widerstand vielleicht nicht in der art
wie das jetzt gerade gehört haben gibt
es das auch in skandinavien
natürlich gibt es auch in diesen ländern
impfkritiker oder menschen die sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen aber proteste
wie wir sie gerade beschrieben haben
bekommen aus österreich oder wie sie aus
deutschland kennen gibt es hier nicht
nicht so großflächig nicht so viele
menschen und es wird auch nicht so viel
über sie berichtet das finde ich auch
ganz interessant also der common sense
der ist tief verwurzelt und
interessant finde ich die strategie der
dänischen regierung die natürlich auch
immer so ein bisschen vorreiter ist
manchmal bei maßnahmen wenn sie zum
beispiel auf die quarantäne regelungen
mal schauen da wählt dänemark einen
recht pragmatischen schritt finde ich
weil sie sagen bei einer erkrankung
bleibt sie bitte zu hause und wenn nur
48 stunden symptomfrei willst kannst du
wieder unter die leute
der korona pass ist dann noch nicht auf
grün geschaltet das kommt einige tage
später also bis man dann wieder ins
restaurant kann das dauert noch ein
bisschen aber man kann eben wieder raus
die begründung ist dass die regierung
sagt länger machen es die leute nicht
und wir können es und wollen es auch
nicht die ganze zeit kontrollieren und
ich glaube dieses entgegenkommen das
könnte ein wichtiger kern baustein sein
warum dieses vertrauensverhältnis auch
in dieser corona zeit bestand hat und in
schweden ist es ganz ähnlich an der
strecke der chef der gesundheitsbehörde
der ist ja über schwiegen hinaus bekannt
geworden durch den so genannten
schwedischen weg die schwedinnen und
schweden hören das nicht so gerne wenn
wir das sagen weil sie sagen wir haben
doch eigentlich das gemacht was ich auch
gemacht habt aber an der stelle hat
natürlich mehr freiheiten zugelassen
über lange zeit als in anderen ländern
der ist dafür richtig gefeiert worden es
gab plakate von ihm und sogar einige
haben sich sein gesicht tätowieren
lassen das ist ja viel sagend also noch
mal hat die schwedische regierung oder
die schwedische gesundheitsbehörde auch
in dieser schwierigen zeit gezeigt sie
kann die kommunikation mit den menschen
und sie kann durch die krise führen und
deswegen ist es womöglich so dass die
impfkritiker hier nicht so stark
vertreten sind wie in anderen ländern
interessant ist dass die
universität in arhus untersuchung
gemacht wir sind eigentlich die menschen
die sich nicht impfen lassen in dänemark
jetzt das ist ja ein kleinerer teil und
sie sagen es sind junge menschen die
ausbildung ist in der regel nicht so gut
viele sind ohne job und man versucht
eben mit überzeugungen diesen letzten
teil in der gesellschaft noch zu
bekommen hatte fredriksen die
ministerpräsidenten in dänemark hat
gesagt wir als regierung stehen an der
seite der 90 prozent die sich haben
impfen lassen und die sich jetzt auch
ostern lassen da ist die quote auch
schon über 50 prozent also wir sind
richtig flott unterwegs in dänemark und
die letzten zehn prozent die sollen
diesen konsens uns doch bitte nicht
kaputt machen also appelle appelle
appelle und weitgehend funktioniert das
wegen seiner haltung zum impfen wird
sich wahrscheinlich in deutschland kaum
jemand das gesicht von olaf scholz
tätowieren lassen er der bundespräsident
auch viele andere spitzenpolitiker
beklagten immer diese gesagt dass es
gebe eine spaltung oder eine ab der
gesellschaft es gebe zu viele konflikte
auch gewalttätige konflikte wegen des
impfens wegen corona wenn man jetzt
sieht also
vielleicht ja die impfpflicht vielleicht
nein doch nicht oder später oder gar
nicht oder dann doch wieder irgendwie
was macht das eigentlich mit diesen
vertrauensverhältnis das gestand lenker
gerade in für schweden angesprochen hat
in deutschland zwischen der politik und
den bürgern ich glaube wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen der kleinen
gruppe der wirklich radikalen impfgegner
die wir auf den demonstrationen sehen
die polizisten angreifen die impfzentren
anzünden das ist eine kleine gruppe die
haben wir verloren und um die müssen wir
auch in dem sinne nicht mehr kämpfen
wenn die unseren rechtsstaat als solchen
nicht akzeptieren um die gruppe die wir
aber kämpfen müssen ist die gruppe große
gruppe der ungeimpften wir haben über 16
millionen ungeimpfte die aber in dem
alter sind oder beziehungsweise die alle
recht sind sich impfen zu lassen ich
rede jetzt nicht von den von kleinen
kindern wirklich für die allen impfstoff
zugelassen ist über 16 millionen und das
sind eben nicht alles menschen die wir
eben auf der straße sehen sondern die
sitzen er zu hause und um die müssen wir
uns kümmern und deren sorgen ernst
nehmen und die haben ganz oft einfach
angst vor der impfung und in diese
ängste müssen wir ihnen nehmen und da
sehe ich im moment nicht genug
engagement seitens der politik sein krad
herrn scholz angesprochen ärztlicher
hingestellt und gesagt wir haben gar
keine spaltung und das ist natürlich der
erste fatale fehler aber wenn wir diese
spaltung erstmal leugnen und sagen na ja
das ist nur eine kleine gruppe dann kann
man sie auch nicht lösen vielleicht eine
definitionsfrage also spaltung wäre wenn
das land in der mitte durch gespalten
werde so ist es ja nicht es gibt ja eine
klare mehrheit die die korona maßnahmen
gut findet und auch eine ganz klare
mehrheit die er auch für die allgemeine
impfpflicht ist deswegen hab ich ja
gerade diesen begriff der abspaltung
also sich her eine kleinere gruppe
radikal und lautstark da absondert und
das gleichzeitig die politik aber eben
als großes problem für den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt so klein
gebe ich ihnen recht ist die gruppe auf
der straße aber die über 16 millionen
die ungeimpft sind das ist schon eine
große gruppe und diese abspaltung sollte
man glaube ich nicht einfach so
hinnehmen sondern sich schon ernsthaft
gedanken machen wie wir die wieder
zurückzukommen und vor allem video geht
eine gemeinsame öffentlichkeit schaffen
also das ist ja auch das grundproblem
wir sind ja zum teil einer
also ganz anderen sphären unterwegs und
würden diese sendung wahrscheinlich auch
nicht schauen sondern um die auf
facebook oder telegramm gucken und da
müssen wir weiterkommen jetzt gibt es ja
in frankreich eine mehrheit die für
diese maßnahmen auch für impfpflicht ist
ob jetzt die partielle für bestimmte
berufsgruppen oder allgemein
die das was wir in frankreich jetzt an
gesetzen verordnungen kommt das kommt ja
von der regierung in deutschland hat
sich die regierung jetzt zurückgezogen
und gesagt da sollte man die im
parlament machen ich glaube in
frankreich werde das eher undenkbar dass
ich einzelne parlamentarier muss man
sagen die nationalversammlung hat auch
nicht die macht und den einfluss den der
bundestag hat
zusammentun und sozusagen jetzt auf gut
glück mal versuchen eine impfpflicht
einzuführen
frankreich ist letztendlich die jetzt
vom national darum das programm des
präsidenten umzusetzen und da wird auch
keine gesetzesinitiative oder auch keine
solche entscheidung getroffen ohne dass
die regierung erst mal darüber nach dem
tod eine entscheidung trifft im
parlament wird natürlich darüber
debattiert aber
das ist das quasi von von vom
von abgeordnete eine solche entscheidung
nach oben treiben würde das kind in
frankreich so oder so nicht passieren
und ich glaube auch wie ich vorhin sagte
dass diese impfpflicht debatte in
frankreich verhindert wird in den
nächsten wochen die maßnahmen die jetzt
getroffen sind jemand will marco
entschieden haben entschieden hat die
werden jetzt in kraft treten und es wird
erstmal reichen für die nächsten vier
fünf monate was nach der
präsidentschaftswahl kommt wenn ihr mann
ihr einmal wiedergewählt wird und
vielleicht nicht genug menschen geimpft
sind das ist natürlich eine andere
geschichte ja du willst du sie kennt die
verhältnisse in deutschland auch und es
gibt ja in österreich auch den
regierungsentwurf der da angebracht
worden ist der morgen abgestimmt wird in
deutschland machen sich also jetzt
verschiedene gruppierungen im parlament
durch alle fraktionen durch wie bei
einem wandertag auf die suche nach der
richtigen form einer möglichen
impfpflicht in deutschland sie sollen ja
auch das hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach jahr zugesichert auch
expertise aus dem gesundheitsministerium
bekommen aber sie sollen sich jetzt erst
mal selbst irgendwie einigen und wie
gesagt dass auf eine relativ informellen
basis machen was ist das für sie
eigentlich dieses verhalten im bundestag
dass jetzt auch herr von der regierung
kommt auch der mutter ist soll das
parlament soll jetzt alles regeln ist
das für sie ein ausdruck von
fortgeschrittenem parlamentarismus oder
ist das politisches gebirge
eigentlich ja deutsche bundestag kann
sicherlich mehr gewicht als unserer
nationalrat wir haben ja ein
unglaubliches politisches jahr hinter
uns wenn man ja mit drei
bundeskanzleramt hinter uns sebastian
kurz der jungstar der politik den wir
vom nachgesagt wurde dass er das
parlament überhaupt nicht schätzt dass
das viel nur einen vollzugsorgane ist
der ist weg jetzt ist sein
nach-nachfolger bereits im amt kann er
haben wir das ist jemand erst viel
verbindlicher jetzt auftritt als er geht
auch auf die oppositionsparteien zu die
beiden die sozialdemokraten und die
liberalen leos werden von zwei frauen
geführt und er hat betont jetzt immer
wieder wie er dankbar denen ist dass sie
diese maßnahmen mittragen dass sie da
mit ihm diesen konsens suchen das im
parlament gibt es eine ganz breite
mehrheit das habe ich ihnen am anfang
das hat gesagt vier von fünf parteien
werden morgen diesen diesen diesen
pflicht beschließen die fünfte spielt
auf
radikalopposition
österreich ist ja auch ein bisschen
dafür bekannt dass wir so durch die
schlampigkeit erfunden haben ich glaube
die die große hoffnung der der regierung
ist dass dieses gesetz nie ernsthaft
vollzogen werden muss wobei die
aktuellen zahlen dramatisch sind werden
heute 27.000 neue fällig ist dann war es
noch 16.000 deutschland hat zehnmal
soviel einwohner wie österreich das
würde einen heißen in deutschland
270.000 fälle am tag da würden binnen
ganz schön die alarmglocken schrillen
aber unsere prognostiker sagen damit hat
berechnet und wir haben auch im moment
noch wie die kollegin schweden oder in
frankreich die hospitalisierung zahlen
sind im moment nicht dramatisch und die
regierung hofft wohl dass die amerikaner
welle abgeebbt sein wird bevor das
gesetz dann wirklich schlagend werden
würde doch bevor das strafen beginnt das
ist große hoffnung dann würde man ohne
großen gesichtsverlust herauskommen und
der vergleich zwischen deutschland
österreich zu haben 270.000 haben sie
gesagt müssten es in deutschland sein
wenn es prozentual so viel sind wie in
österreich waren heute 112000 also
wesentlich weniger banker wenn es doch
nicht so glimpflich abgeht mit corona
das könnte ja immer noch seien neue
virusvarianten wieder auftauchen ist das
trotzdem dann einige mögliche gefahr
dass es doch in den skandinavischen
ländern doch wieder politisch etwas
konfliktträchtige wird dass es
möglicherweise auch zwischen den
parlamenten und regierungen dann wieder
konfliktreicher zugeht
auch da haben wir mal wieder einen
sonderstatus
es gibt auf der politischen bühne kaum
eine diskussion darüber ob der weg jetzt
richtig oder falsch war in schweden wenn
sie sich erinnern ist es ja so gestaltet
dass vor allen dingen in den altenheimen
die lage katastrophal waren pflegekräfte
die die instruktion nicht richtig
verstanden haben die die materialien gar
nicht hatten haben dafür gesorgt dass
die infektionen da richtig rund gegangen
sind und viel zu viele menschen
gestorben sind sei eine
untersuchungskommission eingesetzt
worden die das alles aufarbeiten soll
aber politisch hat man gar nicht erst
versucht daraus kapital zu schlagen wir
haben ja eine sozialdemokratische
minderheitsregierung stefan löfvén war
zunächst der
ministerpräsident die diesen kurs
gefahren hat und die opposition die
hatten da nicht gepackt an diesem punkt
hat gesagt du hast das falsch gemacht
sondern man hat das politisch eigentlich
immer mitgetragen seine nachfolgerin
materiell anders schon hat das abend
übernommen fährt einen ähnlichen kurs
auch da gibt es einen politischen
konsenses die wahlen sind ja im übrigen
in diesem jahr also im herbst ich glaube
das thema krone wird dabei kaum eine
rolle spielen und ähnlich nämlich dass
auch in dänemark war da gibt es diese
politische diskussion einfach nicht
sondern man vertraut darauf dass der
kurs der richtige ist man hat auch
ehrlich gesagt keinen keinen besseren
und etwas überrascht hat mich die
aussage einer dänischen epidemiologin
die die hoffnung
geäußert hat dass nach der omicron bälle
die lage tatsächlich
besser aussehen wird das ist ja auch bei
den kolleginnen kollegen eben in der
runde angeklungen sie sagte nämlich
entweder sind die menschen dann geimpft
oder sie haben auf natürlichem wege eine
krone infektion oder omikron infektionen
hinter sich gebracht und so ist das
immunsystem gestärkt und würde sie
schützen vor möglicherweise weiteren
varianten ob die kommen das weiß keiner
von uns aber die dänen wie die schweden
sind eigentlich recht zuversichtlich
wenn sie in die zukunft gucken und
glauben dass sie das gemeinsam schaffen
werden dass christian banker gerade
gesagt hat ist ja das sagen das virus
oder ascona
endemisch schritt also sich nicht mehr
weiter ausbreitet keine virus varianten
sozusagen zu einer besseren influenza
mutiert das ist ja auch ein argument
gegen die einführung einer allgemeinen
viel zu sagen möglicherweise käme die ja
viel zu spät aber klar ist dass noch
nicht also das ist jetzt eine vermutung
der auch der korona papst in deutschland
christian drosten geäußert halte es für
durchaus wahrscheinlich hatte er
meistens recht mit seinen ankündigungen
welchen einfluss hat das jetzt auf die
politische diskussion hier also hat
osten da haben sie recht da klingt
erstaunlich optimistisch da hat sogar
gesagt man müsste an einigen stellen die
tür für das virus öffnen aber ich glaube
kein politiker traut sich in deutschland
im moment zu sagen na ja aufgrund der
deutlich älteren verläufe von omikron
können wir ausschließen auch bei sehr
hohen infektionszahlen dass es nicht
doch eine zu große gruppe von menschen
gibt die einen zu schweren verlauf haben
dass es eben die große frage jetzt bei
einer insolvenz von über 500 ist das
noch stember aber niemand weiß wie das
in deutschland aussehen wird bei einer
insolvenz von 2000 oder noch höher
deswegen sagt auch karl lauterbach auf
der einen seite wir wollen auf keinen
fall eine durchfeuchtung wir wollen es
nicht so laufen lassen wie in dänemark
oder in großbritannien aber auf der
anderen seite muss man auch sagen sind
wir jetzt aber auch keine wirklich
strenge maßnahmen die diesen anstieg
jetzt verhindern würden also wir haben
zwar die begrenzung auf zehn personen
auch bei geimpften und und getesteten
gewesenen getestete nicht mehr aber dass
da sind sich glaube ich alle einig wird
diese enorme dynamik nicht stoppen und
hey leute was sag ich jetzt na ja man
müsste aus der welle 1 steinhügel machen
aber dann bin ich mal gespannt
wenn ich sie richtig verstanden habe
kritisieren sie ja die allgemeine
impfpflicht wenn sie im moment
eingeführt wird könnte sein dass sie
ihre meinung noch mal ändern müssen bei
einer veränderten pandemie lage das ist
eben die crux das sogar wenn wir die
pflicht jetzt im april zb einführen die
ja gar nicht mehr gegen nikon schützen
wird sondern eben gegen eine variante
die womöglich dann im herbst kommt wo
wir aber nicht wissen wie die verlaufen
wird lauterbach sagt jetzt nein man
könne nicht ausschließen dass sie
genauso in texas die omikron aber noch
viel tödlicher und ich glaube mit einer
pandemie kann man gar nichts niemals
ausschließen aber ob dieses nicht
ausschließen reicht auch rechtlich
gesehen für eine impfpflicht auf
verdacht jemand zu formulieren könnte
das eben eine große frage ist wegen geld
jetzt wirklich vorsichtig dinge zu
beschließen wir gar nicht wissen wann
wir die wie überhaupt anwenden wollen
die gewi möglicherweise jetzt
beschlossen werden im parlament das soll
den solle eine sogenannte gewissensfrage
seien deswegen gibt es auch keinen
fraktionszwang also wir haben in
deutschland der deutschen
parlamentsgeschichte gewissensfragen
gehabt bei der verjährung von mord bei
sterbehilfe bei organspenden wenn das
leben von millionen von menschen bedroht
ist das eine gewissensfrage oder ist das
nicht eine administrative notwendigkeit
dann so zu entscheiden
also die ampel regierung sagt das ist
eine gewissensfrage es war natürlich ein
politisches manöver weil sie eben die
verantwortung von sich weg geben wollten
interessant ist auch an der stelle dass
herr lauterbach er jetzt sagt naja als
minister möchte neutral bleiben liegt
deswegen auch keinen eigenen antrag vorn
weil sie gerade organspende sagte herr
lauterbach selbst seit anfang 2000 20
zusammen mit ihren spaß an der damals
minister war ein antrag vorgelegt als es
um die organspende
ging und das war auch ein antrag von
regierungsseite und damals hatte herr
lauterbach damit kein problem jetzt sagt
er ja oh gott oh gott das geht gar nicht
wir müssen ja neutral bleiben als
ministerium also diese argumentation ist
auch nicht ganz stringent bei corona ist
ja die innenpolitische konflikt
situation in vielen ländern da wenn
jetzt corona ab denn es möglicherweise
verschwindet jedenfalls nicht mehr als
pandemie sondern als emmi da ist was
passiert dann
zum beispiel in frankreich ein land das
für proteste viel
berüchtigter ist als deutschland kommen
dann wieder das thema klimaschutz ist
das sozusagen man wendet sich einem
gewissen thema zu wenn das abgearbeitet
ist für migration jetzt corona da sind
ja auch viele die diese proteste für
ihre eigenen zwecke instrumentalisieren
ist das dann so reingeht das land munter
weiter eben dann mit einem anderen mega
thema also ich glaube dass corona gar
keine so große rolle spielen wird in
frankreich in der präsidentschaftswahl
also in der kampagne bis dahin
weil ihm auch ein konsens da ist dass
die regierung nicht so viel falsch
gemacht hat zumindest jetzt in den
letzten monaten im jahr das ist keine
angriffsfläche für die gegner von
emanuel makro und deswegen merkt man
jetzt schon die kampagne die wie der
wahlkampf wird eben mit themen wie
migration die inflation die kaufkraft
das sind die themen die eben alltag die
franzosen immer noch beschäftigen und
man spürt jetzt schon das ist eigentlich
die tmg am wichtigsten sein wert und ich
glaube rohner wird natürlich eine rolle
spielen die bei uns allen aber ähnlich
wie im deutschen wahlkampf wird es nicht
das hauptthema sein ratkovica wenn das
thema corona die österreicher nicht mehr
erregt was passiert dann
die politische landschaft ist in
österreich so gespalten wie sicher die
haben nicht mehr waren sich war das land
bekannt für einen parteiübergreifenden
konsens der war spätestens mit sebastian
kurz vorbei das land ist wirklich
das glaube ich zum unterschied von
schweden jetzt wenn ich das höre ich
weiß dass auch wenn meine schwägerin
lebt in späten die erzählt mir
eigentlich ist das vertrauen in die
politik ist allgemein sehr gesunden das
ist bedenklich natürlich sind die
hauptthemen dann kommt wieder ums klima
klimaschutz wir haben ja die grünen in
der regierung die es gibt kommt eine
ökologische steuerreform
inflation wird das ganz große thema und
wir haben große sorgen was sich in der
ukraine tut denn es ist mehr von wien an
die ukrainische grenze
ganz nach bregenz wissen da nehme ich
mal an herr banker dass die skandinavier
egal was passiert so resilient so
widerstandsfähig sind dafür mit einem
klarkommen die kurze antwort es sind
gleich am ende der sendung ja nicht mit
allem ich würde sagen in dänemark an die
sozialdemokrat mit matter friedrichs und
das ruder fest in der hand in schweden
wird es richtig spannend denn hier gibt
es innenpolitisch druck
bandenkriminalität ist ein riesiges
thema hier in schweden dass die jetzige
regierung nicht unter kontrolle gekriegt
und ich glaube das wird die bürgerlichen
parteien beflügeln und da wird es
richtig dampf geben also der wahlkampf
wird in schweden spannend ich bedanke
mich hier das war heute eine rundumsicht
durch europa zeigt wie vielfältig dieser
kontinent ist kaya klapse an mayet
robert adrowitzer und christian blacky
lenker vielen dank liebe zuschauer
morgen in der phoenix runde eine
enttäuschende bilanz fragezeichen ein
jahr schoben
jetzt folgt für nichts der tag mit
konstanzer bratzke unter anderem die
pressekonferenz des us außenministers in
tony blinken der war heute in der
ukraine bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]